hey what's up guys my name is the
chanter and welcome to a pretty pretty
much casual video that's just gonna sort
of slightly analyze time which is the
game that I made full of them there
because the results came out like today
or yesterday or whatever so um which I
actually did pretty well okay not gonna
lie I didn't expect this so there's the
results I think we came like number four
hundred or something our overall out of
like two thousand games but in audio
I came tenth so here I am right here and
for mood I got 46 48 I think if we just
take a look here so um these are the
ratings so not bad I mean I'm pretty
happy with that to be honest because
this is a very this is an unfinished
game right this is a prototype yeah so
we're out we rank pretty well audio I
honestly have no idea how I got time for
that I didn't have any sound effects
whatsoever I just had um I just had a
music which I wrote in about not a know
an hour so I wasn't I wasn't great but
um number 59 theme is pretty high as
well so um that's probably the best was
all I've gotten like ever in love and
death it's my third but endure the first
one I did was Genesis in fact I think if
you click on my profile which is uh how
I even do that only if you view my
journal which is some way yeah there it
is or view all entries by churner so
Genesis um Jeff see Genesis go like
number 116 no audio 280 overall to get
better overall but um worse than other
categories squared I think was pretty
bad squared
yeah squared like I didn't even write
any games I don't know how I got barely
any coolness but yeah but so time is
time is good though and it's a very very
cool concept which I've been meaning to
develop for a while now but I just
didn't so just started with uni and
stuff but um yeah so I thought I'd just
share my results with you guys and I
thought I might as well just analyze
some of the code with you just some of
the code with you because otherwise it
will take too long so if you're
unfamiliar with what time is it's
basically a game in which
it's it's more or less a prototype game
that um because the idea I had was very
cool but the reason that I didn't have
time to develop it was because of course
for LUT I'm there I write my games from
scratch and just riding the engine takes
so long takes like 80% of the time so
the idea was when you hit a shifter it
transports you 10 seconds back in time
so if I hit this guy here there you go
you're ten seconds back in time so
that's that's that was the entire
concept really so there's text on the
floor which is a pro from a technical
standpoint there's obviously a clock
here there's well I guess the big
technical thing and this is probably
going back 10 seconds in time but the
other thing people who asked me it were
asking me about was um this thing so
when you hit this there's like a little
cutscene that plays and a lot of people
were like how are you doing that that's
really cool because this is in the video
this is actually the way that I did this
was very very simple basically it was
just I think like 300 frames 300 PNG
images and they were just animated
essentially as if it was an animated
sprite and and then this level which is
just hilarious because at this point I'm
like yes cause it's just gonna be a
prototype so I made this ridiculous
level so the card okay one thing that I
did here probably which was different
from other games
well we haven't covered States yet in
the game programming series so that's
one thing that obviously I implemented
because there's a menu in here obviously
keeps up being on my screen there's a
menu in here obviously and that that
works and stuff but States we haven't
covered what else have we done in menus
otherwise it's pretty it's pretty um
similar it's pretty similar to the rain
game that we're making in game
programming what else is new oh yeah
there's a there's a separate thread here
running for um loading because loading
was very um Kalen geing what it actually
happens and I can't really show you guys
this because it's not on the screen but
you can see that while it's loading it
it actually display the screen that says
loading and that can be updated of
course and that's all thanks to the fact
that we can use threads because threads
is essential
they just enable us to do multiple
things concurrently right they let us
run multiple lines of code essentially
at the same time and so that's why we
can be loading as well as actually
updating our display so if we load on
one thread and update our display on the
other thread we can actually animate our
progress like that now while I didn't
end up making an animated progress bar
because that's just not the time not
that not stuff you have time for when
you have um 48 hours straight again
it pretty much functions the same way
with loading screens so what happens is
um some of the cool stuff I wanted to
cover with you guys is this brother
right here which is very similar to the
animated sprite that we did here you can
see that one on one of the sprite arrays
it now sir private array is I think a
it's essentially just a um an array of
sprites right I think we did pretty much
the same thing in the animated sprite
class and game programming I think
that's like episode um 87 88 ish maybe
even 89 not a hundred percent show there
but you can say that the the width and
height I think is 340 by two 12 of each
sprite and there are 169 total sprites
so you can see it makes a new array with
a hundred Z's nine sprites that's
primarily why the loading took so long
not the best way of doing it I know but
hey I didn't have much I don't have much
time to come up with a better method
here um so that's that's how this Hana
so this is basically identical to the
animated sprite class what we have here
text Oki text is interesting so text is
um text gets get stored as a sprite and
all that happens and by text I mean um
not like not like this text not like
this text or this text but um the actual
text in the level here's our this stuff
this stuff basically just gets it gets a
yes
it's an image right and then what
happens is that image actually just gets
placed on ttle onto the level as a as a
sprite essentially so it's pretty pretty
basic as well and of course it does it
does have that offset so what we in
render sprite office like there is that
offset that intro
it stays there at all time so that's a
pretty basic thing of course that as a
PNG it's not being it is it is me it is
a PNG image but of course it just
ignores the that if color equals if the
color doesn't equal pink them render
that's how we get the D alpha
transparency here okay what else is that
so
levels are pretty basic oh yes let's
cover this okay so there's this thing
called a time line yeah yeah this is
interesting so this is probably the the
most requested topic here so there is
this thing called a time line and this
time line is responsible for actually I
guess storing the state of the game as
the player plays on and while I didn't
have time to absolutely eliminate all
blocks in this and develop it correctly
the idea was definitely there and the
idea of this is basically having an
ArrayList which contains array lists of
vector and vector is a class that
originally just had X&Y but I obviously
added stuff to us so it's not really
truly a vector anymore of course but
what it would do was store the location
and the type and what would happen is
when you when you got um transport at
ten seconds back in time all that would
happen is because in level because it
actually caches the everyone is
essentially every entity in the level
because it caches that stuff once per
second all you would have to do is
literally if you knew what index you
were up to right now you just have to go
back ten indexes and what you would
actually get or index minus ten
essentially and what you would get is a
set of the world ten seconds ago very
cool way of doing a very lightweight
because all we're storing is the type we
don't even storing the object we're just
throwing the type and the x and y that's
two integers and and an enumeration okay
very very lightweight class a couple of
bytes
honestly a bit more than a couple of us
but very very low amount of data here
which I uses almost no memory as well as
I guess contrasted to storing the entire
class which wouldn't be anywhere near as
efficient
and what happens here is a restore time
okay
so there is still time method and the
time line method so what happens is um
you can say that this is an array list
of vectors here and its local variable
and for every entity essentially what
happens is it gets um we created and we
add it to the to the UM to the eraser
guys to probably see here what's
happening roughly so um again we created
new we create a new entity that contains
the appropriate entity in the entities
array which is of course our array of
every single entity that's currently in
the level and we create a vector out of
that so a vector object out of that
which don't take it as a mathematical
vector clearly it's not but um it's just
called vector because I didn't bother
changing the name so vector dot type so
we could we um I guess yeah I guess we
said we set the type here equal to what
we want it to be and then we add the
vector essentially into the thing with
the appropriate type as a new vector
object so it's um it's pretty basic here
and of course then we add this array so
it creates a vector object out of every
entity in the in the level at that
particular second and adds it and all it
stores about them is the type of entity
they are and their position that's it
of course I guess you'd probably say
that it's not not in the strictest sense
because we don't store where they go to
next so in other words what happens is
if you go back and up well I guess
that's kind of realistic right because
we're not going back in time in terms of
um actually to replay something right
we're just going back in time to um you
know and then of course we can change
the future if that makes sense so we're
not trying to replay our actions as if
we were I don't know going back as seen
on a DVD where I'm which is actually
literally going back in time and that's
why of course everything is different
the second time around so we don't need
saw that so all we need to do is store
store entities locations on on the level
essentially
one time and then on restore time what
happens is the player class the player
has when it when it collides with the
shifter here level don't restore time
fires and travel time is actually set to
negative ten here so what happens is it
restores time the parameter here is time
which is essentially the time we got
plus equals time and because of course
this is a negative value because we want
to you know in restore time he gets as
time but that doesn't make any sense but
the point is that I'm it's adds negative
ten here and let's see I haven't read
this code in like it since long there by
the way so I'm just refreshing myself
here as well that's why I said it would
be fairly casual so if it's lesson start
time of course we said that it and ankle
today everyone which means that the play
essentially loses because if you go back
too far then well you're an exist yet in
the level that's why you lose the game
which is what happens here so oh yeah
but yeah okay so essentially what
happens is it says so start time is
actually set to 7,500 and the reason is
if we set it to zero here and we launch
our game obviously the time it's gonna
be um zero here okay and like it just
come doesn't look very cool I just I
just thought it'd be nicer if it was um
not exactly
midnight so I set it to UM two four ten
I don't know I just added 7,500 seconds
here and there's a nice little algorithm
I guess not only now go to not really an
algorithm but it basically just um sorts
out this time into seconds minutes and
hours okay um and the other thing is
yeah and then all the does here is
essentially restore the restore all the
entities into its into their locations
so I think that's pretty much it
nothing here is really to ground prior
to groundbreaking except for that the
way I handle levels is the same way that
you would have seen in the game
programming series shifters are this is
some a this is some like this a is and
a really AI it's um in fact there is a
small bug in the game which I know I
know about but never fixed this really
should be X hey nya
and essentially what just happens is
every now and then the shift will change
which way they're moving so very basic
AI but um that's what we'll cover soon
in game programming and of course we
will go into some actual AI the thing is
though I didn't want any other AI just
wanted like it's not the reason I didn't
make I didn't make proper AI for this
was not because um not because I didn't
have time or anything it's just because
um so you can see they look a lot better
and then that some people particles here
as well but alright yeah so you can
simply touch them I go back in time um
so yeah the reason I didn't make proper
AI here is because I didn't want like I
didn't really want this shift is to be
following the player or anything or
chasing him I thought that um if they
would just roam randomly hey that would
be a lot I get I guess spookier because
um you have no idea when they're gonna
change direction they were a random
chance to tend to change direction into
a random direction like every tick
essentially every update and now that
gives you like it's kind of a serious
factor because you can't predict their
movement at all it's random and because
of that I think that career predator
really nice feeling and mood I guess an
aesthetic but also like it just fit it
just you know these guys is sort of here
for ambience that's why the shifters are
really here so I'm I thought that was
just a really cool addition to federal
and so far back in time with one
spot so yes there is a way to win the
game course and if you guys haven't
played it yet they'll be a link enter in
the description but what I was gonna do
is essentially develop this in C++ and
OpenGL maybe for my distinction project
for university because I have to do
something black in like OpenGL or
something but we'll see I don't know I
make too many promises but um I think
this game is a pretty cool idea so if I
have time which I definitely will over
the summer holidays which is guys in
holidays but for that you know I will
have time for that so you know we'll see
we'll see ok but I hope you guys did
enjoy the game I had a blast making it I
am I learnt a few things about Java such
as um the way that it copies objects in
the way that it handles pointers to
objects because of course in simple
spells and stuff you have to specify
what you want to be a point of what you
want to not be a pointer in Java it just
kind of does that automatically so you
have no idea like you know integers by
default of course on pointers but
objects I'm still undecided whether
objects and pointers or not I didn't
think they are but like a razor pointer
so if you pass an array through a if you
pass an array through a parameter then
it ends up being ham a pointer so I
guess that is a pass by reference kind
of thing there but I did learn a heap
again I had a lot of fun with you guys
because that was like 250 viewers like
most of the time so I'm I had a really
good time with you guys and I did answer
a lot of questions so I hope you guys
did enjoy this stream but I'll
definitely be doing next bottom deck
because that'll be true in my break as
well and one other thing I'm doing
though is because I think the problem
honestly the problem with this game or I
guess the the reason that I I think I
didn't play SIA was probably because I'm
I just didn't I just ran out of time
okay and I spent like 20 hours
developing this I know every to every
learner there I'm like yes I'm totally
gonna stay awake for like 48 hours I end
up like going in bed sleeping like 9 to
10 hours per night as well as like doing
other work but the other thing is
there's just because I write it from
scratch there's not enough time and I
don't want to use like because okay this
is another thing
so much the top games here if we
actually have a look this is the top
game that one called probe I hadn't had
a blast playing it it is written in all
written like with unity course it is all
these guys are using actual frameworks
actual library is actual like you've
seen it he's more of a SDK even it's
more of like a game and some kind of
thing people are using all this stuff
and because of that they're focusing
less on the graphics I'm on the gameplay
and that's really the thing that wins of
course I don't want to be spending this
much time on graphics which is why I
like honestly for the past year I've
actually been developing a framework
that I'm fast track's game development
in a very very simple way as well that
um that you guys are all used to as well
so hopefully I'll be able to use that
framework as well as well as release it
to you guys by Nexon death so I think
that'll be great and the thing is that
will actually luminate the need to just
type all this code over and over again
and old really make make the gaming make
the game development more focused on the
gameplay which is something that I think
it's very important so um yeah
anyway that's gonna wrap up this video
guys I'll probably see you on Thursday
night with another episode of Gabriel
ramming but until then let it guys